bent u trouwens
want u wilt dus uit de Europese Unie
wilt u ook uit de navo nog
ja dat lijkt me 1 verstandig
punt om te overwegen
maar u zegt zelf dat het inderdaad moet worden over ja
en u zegt nu ja
1 verstandig punt om te overwegen is
wij in onze verkiezingen staan dat
we het willen overwegen
maar wat vindt de lijsttrekker
het lijsttrekker neigt naar uittredingen ja
maar u zegt
we zouden dat aan de bevolking moeten voorleggen
perreferent lijkt me 1 uitstekend idee
maar de laatste keren dat dat is gepeld
was 1 meerderheid van de bevolking
voor het lidmaatschap van de navo
stel nou dat de bevolking zich uitspreekt
voor het lidmaatschap van het bondgenootschap
is daarmee dan de kous af
en laat u het dan verder met rust
dan zullen we ons natuurlijk neerleggen bij de mening
van de bevolking
want wij zijn
democraten in hart en nieren
dat betekent niet dat je vervolgens niet
het gesprek kan voortzetten met elkaar en
De Dingen zijn in
continue ontwikkeling
dus over 1 jaar of 2 jaar is de situatie weer Anders
en je kunt natuurlijk altijd weer opnieuw
met elkaar in gesprek zijn
met vragen van willen we het nog steeds